Такий вигляд має гуманітарна катастрофа на Донбасі.
Мешканці цього району у прифронтовому селищі Новгородське
принесли весь свій посуд, щоб отримати
кількадесят літрів води для своїх родин.
Полювання за омріяними літрами - їхній головний клопіт відтоді,
як у селищі понад місяць тому
відключили централізоване водопостачання.
"Водовоз" приїздить до них не частіше двох разів на тиждень.
Води на всіх не вистачає. Люди в розпачі.
Кажуть, забули навіть про війну, хоча стрілянину тут чути кожен день.
- У мене лежача бабуся - 90 років.
Мені кожен день потрібно її купати, прати їй!
Хіба це можливо з цими відрами і двома пляшками?
Нас троє дорослих!
- Це водомор! Справжній водомор.
Такого в житті не було, щоб людей залишали без води.
Перекрити воду! Сорок градусів жари, а ми сидимо без води.
- Подбайте, щоб у нас вода була вдома.
Я сорок років працювала на фермі.
Залишилась калікою.
А нам привозять по десять відер води на тиждень.
У своїй біді громадяни звинувачують владу -
і місцеву, і центральну київську.
Уже кілька разів збиралися на мітинги.
І без того хитка лояльність остаточно поступилася класовій ненависті.
- Вони на "Мерсах" роз’їжджають! Хіба це слуги народу?!
Місцеві чиновники й комунальники вже місяць
працюють у режимі надзвичайної ситуації,
хоч і офіційно не оголошеної.
Воду розвозять навіть пожежними машинами.
Частина Новгородського отримує воду принаймні кілька годин на добу зі свердловин.
Проте близько чотирьох тисяч мешканців
повністю залежать від підвозу технічної води.
Вода з кранів у Новгородському
та кількох інших населених пунктах біля лінії фронту
зникла, коли насосні станції комунального підприємства "Вода Донбасу"
відключили від електрики через величезні борги перед енергопостачальниками.
Селищний голова Новгородського визнає:
від вирішення кризи залежить не мало й не багато - авторитет української влади на Донбасі.
- Уряд і президент зобов’язані втрутитися.
Ми маємо показати людям на іншому боці, що
в нас життя краще, що тут добре жити і що Україна - це європейська держава.
Наразі ці критерії порушуються: ми не даємо людям воду.
Це серйозне порушення.
Я прошу допомоги у всіх, хто має таку можливість,
зокрема в міжнародних організацій.
Допоможіть нам вирішити цю проблему.
Допоможіть нам із підвозом води, допоможіть нам із бутильованою водою,
тому що в нас є проблема з підвозом води маломомобільним людям, інвалідам.
У Києві на критичну ситуацію з водопостачанням на Донбасі
відреагували лише через кілька тижнів після виникнення проблеми.
Прем’єр-міністр Володимир Гройсман доручив
забезпечити безперебійне постачання електроенергії
підприємству "Вода Донбасу" для відновлення централізованого водопостачання.
Проте вимоги прем’єра було проігноровано.
Як розповіли нам у Донецькій облдержадміністрації,
відрізаними від централізованого постачання води
залишаються понад 30 тисяч мешканців регіону.
Ще майже 110 тисяч отримують воду не цілодобово.
Часто вода відсутня й через інші причини:
аварії на зношених водогонах або пошкодження внаслідок обстрілів.
За словами заступниці директора департаменту ЖКГ Донецької ОДА,
проблеми з доступом до води час від часу
одночасно мають до 400 тисяч мешканців області.
- Ситуація дуже критична.
У нас вже був спалах інфекційних хвороб у Костянтинівському районі.
Це підтверджує держспоживслужба України.
Цей спалах був пов’язаний саме з відключенням води при високій температурі повітря.
Такий спалах ми можемо чекати кожного дня.
По-друге, наші водогони, які сьогодні знеструмлені,
в які не поступає вода - технічно вони руйнуються.
Коли централізоване водопостачання на Донбасі
нарешті відновлять, чиновниця прогнозувати не береться.
Каже, що вирішити ситуацію можна було б,
змінивши законодавство таким чином, щоб
унеможливити відключення електроенергії
на об’єктах комунального підприємства "Вода Донбасу" навіть за несплату.
Адже значна частина області - це прифронтові райони.
Половина боргу "Води Донбасу" - це заборгованість водоканалів із окупованих територій.
Щоби зменшити залежність від дій енергопостачальників,
влада на рівні області та на місцях працює
над програмами резервного забезпечення водою.
Ставку роблять на свердловини.
Утім, визнають чиновники, на це підуть місяці.